[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are gonna be showing you some pretty
cool stuff right now what we have is we
have super human which is this amazing
fast email software and it just hacks
productivity like nothing I've ever done
before and this is totally been
mind-blowing for me and I want to share
it with you I've shared it with a bunch
of ecosystems of different organizations
that I helped mentor for and that just I
know would love to use this so it's be
really interesting to for you guys to
check it out and I have even some action
items for you down how to get started
with it if you're interested so I'm
gonna go ahead and show you what I have
on my screen here what I have is I have
my email and what I'm doing right now is
I'm kind of just you know I'm kind of
just browsing through my email right
here and I'm just pressing J and K like
hotkeys are amazing on this and so what
I'm gonna do is I can press ENTER to
open up an email and then I can move
through my emails pretty easily through
J and K again or I can just do something
simple I click the escape button and go
back and when I click things open like
this you know like this camera like this
camcorder recommendation I can press
ENTER again and I'm creating a draft to
everyone I can go here and I can make a
snippet which is very interesting this
is you know if you press basically
command and then a colon I can use a
snippet and here what I can do is I can
write something like an intro right and
so I can say right here if I want to
make an intro I would say something like
this I would send this to my friend that
I'm asking to make the intro and I'll
zoom in I think to make it to make it
even easier for you if I can yes I can
fantastic let's see if I can scroll down
now for you okay so what I did here is I
wrote an intro to send to Naveen for
Naveen to introduce me to
- Neil and so in this case a Naveen
would have written hi Neil I want to
introduce you Alan who a simulation will
to display daily show he'd love to help
achieve his goals feature on the show
etc and so I have this preset and saved
which makes it super easy for me to do
anything I want with these templates so
it can be and making an introduction it
can be extortion can be sending your
people a promotion or asking for a
referral or all these different sorts of
customer service messages all this kind
of different stuff so I want to show you
guys how easy it is to just be able to
use these templates that are very simple
and then you know you can do simple
things like you can do you know if you
if you make a a : let's say so that was
command : now if you just make a : and
then if you write smile I can add an
emoji like a smile if I want to write
rocket I can have a rocket emoji and so
it makes it really easy to you know to
add emojis and add these emotional
expressions into what we're what we're
drafting in our email and it makes it
really fast to just go through our email
and whatnot so other interesting things
are that I can you know press f2 forward
this email I can add attach items into
this email quite easily so you know I'll
press escape and I'll go back here and
I'm gonna you know I'll take you over to
my you know I have a split inbox here
there's Allen sake and up here there's
simulation series over here it's a
different inbox so if I click that one
open you know a lot of what you see here
is basically just you know people
subscribing to our channel and stuff but
but if I want it you know I'm browsing
I'm browsing through things here and if
I wanna if I want to archive something I
just press e right so okay here's the
subscription to our channel I'm just
gonna press E and archive it
here's another subscription just can
press E and archive it just like that
and so it makes it really fast to just
go through your inbox again now I'm
going to bounce over to you know Alan
sake and where I have a split inbox
because what I have is important
messages in this one and then I have
other messages in this one and what
other messages are is more like kind of
like advertisements and stuff things
that I do sometimes read I do sometimes
read my big think articles you know this
advertisement for YouTube music I'm
go ahead and archive that it's cedra and
so you know this advertisement for
Google one I'll go ahead and archive
that I'll press E and archive it just
like that so let's say that you know I'm
back in my important inbox and I've
shown you kind of how you can pretty
easily you can add snippets by you know
by just doing something as simple as you
know G is G means go to write so I can
go to my G eyes go to inbox GT is go to
your sent box GD is go to drafts and it
just makes hot King really easy and then
you can go to your snippets by pressing
G colon and go to your snippets so this
is just very fast hotkey email software
super easy to use and just hacks into
productivity and makes it super fast and
super easy and I highly recommend
checking it out I wrote information in
the bio below on how to get started with
it if you're interested
this cost 30 bucks a month per person
it's the best expense you'll ever pay
for that's one dollar per day for just
accelerating your internet productivity
massively and you're sorry email
productivity massively so below you'll
see an email Sahar SAH a are at
superhuman calm and if you email her and
say that Alan from simulation referred
you that she will totally take good care
of you and sign you up for it and you
know we don't get paid anything for
doing this
this is strictly because this kicks ass
and helps us tremendously so we want to
pass it along to you and I'm serious
about that it's crazy we don't get paid
for these these partnerships that we
have which you know may be you know
these are just things that we believe in
that we really just believe them in and
have a strong value association with and
you know if you guys believe in us as
well help us out
become patrons of the space help us out
so we can continue introducing you to
really cool hacks like this I just said
that this is a hack this is a hack for
you guys it's a hack to make you guys
better
we'll keep introducing cool stuff like
this to you comment below with your
thoughts subscribe we'd love to start a
little community chat about how this
works and why it's so easy
and sharing more cool stuff like this
with the world thank you everyone for
tuning in we really appreciate it give
Sahar an email and go and try this stuff
out thanks Ron for producing and
directing the show much love everyone
peace
[Music]